hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
December 12 2022
how are you what's going on how are you
how you doing how you doing
um Jesus Christ
you know you know when you try to
[__] look I'm just jumping right in I
don't give a [__] you know when you just
go to [__] look something up
what is the origin of this
right
and what do they do you get on the thing
there's a zillion [__] ads and they
rewind the [__] story like nine
months nine years nine decades nine
[__] centuries
let's like literally just goes like well
first of all why are we asking this
and I'm like who can't say [__] I just
want the [__] answer
that's literally like sitting there
saying to somebody like hey what's two
plus two
well before we say that uh answer that
what are numbers and why did we feel the
need to create them my dumb ass finally
figured out that the reason why they do
that is so that you have to keep reading
this [__] while all these ads go by and
they get credit for you [__] looking
at them
and you know what I mean it's is there
one [__] honest [__] in the world
and it all comes down to the fact that
it's one giant Ponzi scheme and these
[__] suits have us all Scamper and
trying to make a [__] dollar as much
as we can which by the way
buy the [__] way where the [__] did
all these Bitcoin people go
Jesus Christ they were up my ass dude
you're out of your mind you're out of
your mind
you didn't get Bitcoin and I just kept
saying to them like dude
do you think
that this giant Ponzi schemes gonna let
this little Ponzi scheme start a whole
new [__] Ponzi scheme
they're not
I am jumping out of the frying pan Into
the Fire these things are the exact same
[__] thing there's nothing behind it
but a belief system and the second the
belief is gone the [__] thing
collapses that's basically what it is
all right so at that point what I have
to do is I gotta look to see who's the
biggest [__] Bearer in this territory
because it's gonna kill the other one
that's what I did now I know some of you
are going to run immobile you know I
actually bought it Edition now it's only
trading it yet I think it's going to
make a comeback you know what I hope it
does
I hope it does I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] anymore you know
it's like I already have enough
misinformation on this [__] podcast
and every once in a while I actually
want to try to get at least an answer
God knows it will be right
you know I start to read one [__]
answer and it's like it's just Fades
away and goes you need a subscription
all right I respect that you worked
okay I get it
so then I go to the free [__] place
then I guess what they have to do
because then I can chart Ah that's what
it is they don't want to charge me for a
subscription so now they're going to
start filibustering
oh brother
was it really
worth getting that upset about
now this is all misdirected anger
um two more days on the film there's one
last piece of music we're putting in I
thought it was all right and now
somebody has a question about the oboe
or whatever the [__] is on the track so
now I have to listen to the track again
to see if the oboe is lifting the joke
up pulling it down or making people
listen to the oboe and not the joke all
right this is what my 2022 has been like
I'm gonna tell you right now
all right and I'm not going to tell you
later I have so much [__] respect
for anybody
who ever who's ever done this I don't
give a [__] what the result was
anybody who's ever done this and not
just completely lost their [__] mind
is uh incredible I had no idea
I had no idea how lucky I was just to
act in something
and be out there and be to be or not to
be dude hey that's my [__] question
and that's a wrap on Bill Burr and they
clapped me out and I just [__] leave
I go out I get myself a [__] French
dip I'm not acting I can put on a few
right
sit down mouth hanging open oh you in my
[__] beard
and meanwhile what I just walked away
from is is is gonna go on for another
year
of people just sitting there missing
events missing loved ones and all of
this [__] sitting there trying to figure
out whether they need strings guitars a
[__] triangle
you know or what whatever the [__] they
need
to make the [__] General leads seem
like it's flying a little little few
feet higher
well I would try the French horn here
all right let's let's audition that
okay we have ten different uh French
horn tracks to look at
um
so but I will tell you this the [__]
move is great
um
um I know you guys think I'm dying
you know aren't we all a little bit
inside
I'm not I'm I'm much better it's just
I'm gonna cough like a [__] Maniac
because I was like 9 000 feet in the air
the whole [__] weekend in Boise Idaho
beautiful
Boise Idaho beautiful
Salt Lake City beautiful beautiful
Colorado Springs you know
in all of those places all of those
places why I'm [__] Billy two times
right now
like if you ever just want to see a
divide
between the Haves and the have-nots
you gotta you go to those parts of the
country absolutely you either have a
[__] million acres in your own
goddamn Vineyard
with some tricked out [__] Log Cabin
you know
or you like this guy we saw in this Sub
Shop
we went in to get these sandwiches and
he was the nicest [__] guy and you
could just see that like life had just
you know this guy had been through a lot
of [__] you know was having difficulties
moving his left side
you know and he was missing some teeth
so I was thinking oh man you know I was
talking to my buddy I was on the road
with I was like man why do you think
happened that poor guy
seems like a real nice guy what do you
think happened you know
the Back stories do you think he oh deed
man is that way you know one of his
sides you know maybe passed out and got
nerve damage on his [__] arm or some
[__] like that but then he was also
wearing a cowboy hat so it's like did he
[__]
get thrown off a bull
and stomped on and I know that sounds
nuts if you don't [__] live out there
but where I where I [__] performed at
it's one of the coolest venues I've ever
performed at in that they they usually
have like like rodeos there and bull
riding [__] and everything and I saw
where they put like the livestock and
all of that and it was just this old
badass [__]
venue that looked like it had some sort
of AHL action in it possibly at some
point or maybe roller derby
or God knows what what bands play I
played some really cool places
on this whole tour and um
anyway the crowd was amazing
um one of my buddies that I worked with
on F is for family was up there
uh Peter Billingsley just happened to be
in town and uh he came by he has uh a
new movie out and he's going to be on my
podcast coming up soon
um
so I got to hang out with him for a
minute and uh
and one of my uh one of the guys that
taught me how to fly
a helicopter he was in town
and uh
I got to talk to him you know he was
breaking my balls about my skill level
and all of that [__] to the point I was
trying no I'm actually I'm I'm good now
I'm okay
this poor guy one time we were in a
Robinson
and we went to uh
enter an auto rotation right and uh
let's see here my brain's going to be
backwards because
the one that I fly now the pedals are
opposite whatever way you're supposed to
stomp down on the pedal I Stomp the
other way I stomped on the wrong one and
he stopped me and we would have we
basically would have been doing like I
don't know what
360s
um
and I brought that up and he started
cracking up
he still remembered it
um so I had a great time up there
but I kind of noticed that when I was up
there it was just like
you know
I don't know
these [__] drugs man
just hit these places like so [__]
hard I don't I don't how do you have you
seen that [__] commercial that's on
TV where they're talking about like the
Fentanyl and all of that type of stuff
and like
you know they're putting in the these
all these different drugs now and people
are [__] dying I mean Jesus Christ
I don't know what what is wrong with
people can't you just deal drugs
do you have to kill people
I'm talking about the pharmaceutical
industry too it's just [__] you know
this is like the I don't know I I've
gone to all of these places and you know
I remember a long time when I was in
Reading Pennsylvania there was this
beautiful woman behind the counter I was
buying a cup of coffee and she was
sweetheart she smiled and she had like
those meth teeth and stuff I could tell
she was sober and all of that it's like
yeah you look at all of this [__] it's
like these are the people we should be
trying to help out you know if they're
worthy of helping out I'm not saying if
they're [__] dirt bags and they're
still you know
being Shifty or whatever or whatever the
[__] deal is then you don't want to
throw good money after bad after that
but like there's got to be a way to help
those people out you know
um
so anyway uh shout out to that guy
because he was a [__] sweetheart of a
guy and he could just see him and he
went through a lot of [__]
um that guy at the sandwich place great
sandwich by the way uh so we did that
one couldn't [__] sleep that night
and I was thinking like God what am I
stressing about somebody finally told me
it was the altitude
um
and then we played this this hockey
arena on uh
let's see that was Salt Lake City which
I'd been there in forever I had a blast
with those people
I just kept talking to all of them like
they had 12 wives which like I know they
all do but like I was saying like you
know that's why they have uh the big
Salt Lake there because one one of them
gets out of line you know when you kill
him it's an easy place to dump the body
so uh and they were cool as [__]
um
oh that's right I was riffing on that
and I said you guys got like a term for
that do you call it getting Pro Vote or
something like that
um and then the last one I did Colorado
Springs and that's where that you know
that [__] idiot shut up that gay club
man it's just
I don't know I was sort of depressed by
the end of the Run
of uh going to these beautiful places
and seeing you know
tragedy you know but then there's also
then it's like what's so [__] weird
is then there's just these gorgeous
snow-covered mountains in the background
it's literally God's country but uh
I don't know I don't ever remember
seeing [__] like when I first started
doing the road now once again I might be
an old guy romanticizing this [__] but
like you know I don't know I don't know
if if
I'm just more aware of it
or what but I feel like I'm starting to
see that Gap that they were talking
about the shrinking of the middle class
and all that because it just seems I
don't know all right that's depressing
sorry I had to get that off my [__]
chest
um so anyway
you know as much as I've been making fun
of the World Cup and all that it was
funny actually been watching
uh
as much of it as I can
and it was funny because some guy said
to me um
he said to me on the internet he goes
why are you watching this stuff I
thought you [__] hate it I was like
dude I'm just trying to stir you [__]
up
just trying to get you going you know
what I mean see who takes the [__]
bait
what am I supposed to do say like the
World Cup is an amazing event it's
actually one of the few true world
champions championships because the
whole world competes
you know is that going to make you Tweet
back
no what if I say ah there's a bunch of
[__] rolling around on the [__]
grass like they got shot by by a [__]
gun and then they're up two seconds
later run around and then all you [__]
are gonna drop your fish and chips and
you're gonna start writing me all right
there's a method to my madness so um
anyway I the only one I got to watch a
little bit of I don't know who the [__]
I was watching
I watched Iran versus the US and then I
I saw a little bit of the US get the
[__] kicked out of him by the
Netherlands and then I saw another one I
don't know who was playing
Morocco
uh Marblehead I don't know who was
playing
um I saw only a little bit of that but I
watched
pretty much all of France
versus England
and I was watching that thing and they
kept talking about how England was
saying it's coming home
like that was their thing and that
really [__] bugged me
like it's coming home like what if if
France wins it again the trophy isn't
home why is why is where the [__] you
guys live home it just you know what it
did it reminded me of when the Yankees
win the World Series and all those [__]
on ESPN Go and everything what do they
say and everything
is right in baseball
that's what they say and everything is
right in baseball it's why what because
Mr Smithers has the [__] trophy
look I get Yankee fans saying that but
like the ESPN guys is supposed to kind
of be impartial right a little bit when
the end all is right in baseball it's
right if what is it wrong if the rest of
us win it [__] are you talking about so
something about that was bugging me then
I was like well wait a minute
did the game originate in England I know
everybody oh Jesus doesn't know it I
don't [__] know anything because I
asked these questions
where did the game of soccer originate
and then I'll go on a page and be like
well in order to figure out where it
originated we need to figure out why we
play sport what was the first during
Roman times
and by then I'm just like just [__]
answer the question
it's a question Chuck
um so I don't know somebody from England
what are you sad [__]
after that [__] brutal loss I'm gonna
tell you this right now the penalty kick
is the stupidest [__] thing I've ever
seen in my life first of all the
assumption that if you didn't kick that
[__] dude in the leg and he went down
that he was automatically going to score
a goal
or maybe they do that because they're
basically it's like if you do that [__]
in here we're just going to give a goal
because if we didn't you'd be doing it
all the [__] time and then this game
would be extra [__] low scoring maybe
that's what it is I don't know but I can
tell you this I'm not looking it up
in order to answer that what is the
history of grass
um
what on what day did God invent it
you know before [__] what's her face
took her shorts off whatever they said
happened
typical broad you know she's in paradise
and she's still looking for something
better
unbelievable you know that's the one
story in the Bible that I believe the
rest of it sounds like horseship but
whenever the adamant when her [__]
going off and [__] eating it it's
like yeah you know what that that tracks
that [__] track she probably had a
whole bunch of [__] apple trees but
she never ate an apple off of that one
never ate apple off that one and just
peaked her [__] curiosity
uh sorry
all right I'm I'm in a fight I'm in a
[__] mood here
um anyway
so I watched that goddamn game and uh
yeah it was weird like the the
um this is why I don't like the I get I
guess I understand why you have to have
the penalty kick
um but you're basically giving the other
team a goal or you're ending a person's
public life
that's basically it
is he just going to give him a go
or the poor bastard's gonna miss it
and if he misses it or bottles it or
whatever the [__] they say which I
looked up the origin of that
once they waited me through the history
of [__] bottles they said that back
in the day they used to call your your
ass a [__] bottle
basically meant you [__] yourself
I think
I don't know after we after surfing
through uh scrolling past All Those ads
I don't even know what the [__] it meant
so this poor guy
he already has I'm gonna [__] it up face
right this is why I don't believe in a
God that cares he gives him that [__]
face and then this poor [__] goes up
there right and I'm and I'm sitting
there yelling at the [__] TV going
like all right so the French have to
earn their goals and you're just gonna
give it to them
um oh speaking of which there was one
guy one [__] guy I forget what team
he was I think he was wearing the white
shirt the English guy right English guy
[__] flops better than anybody I've
ever seen in the NBA and then when there
isn't a call
the performance that he gave afterwards
like he just couldn't [__] believe
he gave such a performance
that they didn't call the assault that
had happened to him that they went to
the replay to see what happened and he
basically brushed against some guy and
then threw himself on the [__] ground
so anyway
this [__] guy gets up there I swear
to God if he was a woman he'd never have
a date in his life just the Plain Jane
[__] oval face
just yeah I just looked at him I'm like
you know
I don't know
I don't know what his deal is right
vaguely look like Roger Daltrey
same [__] maybe he grew up in the
same [__] near the same near the same
Hedgerow or whatever Robert Plant used
to sing about sorry I'm old
um
so he [__] goes up there and
I think if the goalie guesses
it blocks the thing I think you're all
right
you know
but but if you just completely missed
the net like this guy did he [__]
roofed it right
it was like he was winding up to kick
the ball and he saw some titties in the
upper deck and you know the ball went
where his [__] eyes went I don't know
what happened he kicks it over the
goddamn goal
he bottled it right he shed himself
then that's basically that guy can't
[__] go anywhere
for how long English people how long
you know
I mean these countries you do that you
go back there they're going to kill you
right
[__] pressure man
um
yeah it was like and then I I just I
felt so bad for the guy
going like
now for the rest of his [__] life
everywhere he goes
some of the most out of shape drunk
people who can't even [__] tie their
own shoes without turning beat red and
doing a [__] somersault
right are now going to judge him in his
athletic ability
and his ability in a pressure moment
like all these fat fish and chip eaten
[__] deliver in the moment
you know
when you look into a crowd in any
athletic event or possibly if you look
at a bunch of podcast hosts
if you really look into our eyes most of
us don't deliver nobody delivers
and I got that level the whole [__]
world is watching
I don't know man so
as much as I made fun of them I felt bad
for that guy so uh I will say this
before you yell at that guy just think
of all the times you [__] blown it in
life I guess because he's blowing it for
everybody else
you know what it is is he has
everybody's crushed dreams crushed hopes
and dreams on his foot
right then if he misses it's an outlet
for everybody else who didn't go go for
it in life who's going through a tough
time Jesus this is a dark one I'm sorry
um anyway but the French are going to be
uh looking to repeat I'm gonna watch it
from here on out
um
oh gee thanks Bill thanks for joining
the rest of the world we're so honored
to have you
um
uh two more days in the film three more
dates
and then I'll have all the time in the
world to watch the World Cup and it's
going to be [__] over football
season's basically going to be over at
least the playoffs are coming around
um
a bunch of crazy games today as far as
what I saw after I landed Jesus Christ
San Francisco was kicking the [__] out
of Tampa Bay so [__] bad they shut
the game off in my area
you know my son had come down
you know when I came home he was still
he was still taking his nap and he came
down you know he was doing his thing
where he just like whines
he died his truck
got his truck
he's used to me saying no I'm watching
the game
I went like you want to ride my truck
and he was like yeah
and I go all right let's go and he goes
yeah he like [__] freaks out I mean
it's all an act all the whining is just
he just knows that I'm a softy
you know
Apple
and I just I just I can't I'm like all
right all right buddy I'll [__] you
want me to slice it up yeah it gets all
excited so um
the game was still on it was halftime
they were up like [__] 28 to nothing
unfortunately one of their their star
running backs or something like that
hurt his knee I hope that guy was all
right that was brutal to watch
um
so I took him for a ride in my truck
and we had like the best time
and uh
you know I came back put the truck away
and uh you know the garage is basically
mine I'm a typical guy so my drum Kit's
out there too so he gets out of the
truck he's like Dad boom boom bap boom
boom bap you want to play the drums he's
like yeah so we played the drums for a
while
you know so I was probably gone for like
a half hour maybe
total
and I came back and the game was off and
I was like oh [__]
it was kind of bugging me it's like how
many times does Tom Brady have to make a
[__] amazing comeback that she that
you'd actually shut this game off in my
market so they ended up turning on um
the Seahawks Panthers I had money on
that game I don't know what ended up
happening but who who the [__] saw the
Panthers without Baker Mayfield
going into the most artificially loud
venue
in American Sports
you know they don't need to pump In
Crowd noise
they figured out a way around it
they built a [__] Opera House the
same way they built them before uh the
amplification of sound
and these [__] guys were going in
there
they they were in the lead I don't know
what the hell happened but
just those weird games I was like well
you know what I probably didn't do that
well this week against bed MGM
um so
anyway I ended up bringing my son inside
and uh his mom had his dinner ready so I
sat him down and I had to bring my
luggage back out to the garage
you know old house not a lot of closet
space so I [__] put in the garage
right
and uh
I was like you know what I'm gonna sit
down play some drums you know I've been
working on some stuff I was sort of like
thinking about [__] that I wanted to
play and I went down and sat at the kid
and played for 40 minutes and I
absolutely [__] sucked
oh my god did I suck
you know I was excited to play so I
didn't stretch enough and I'm [__]
old
you know the garage was cold my limbs
were cold and all of that and I sat down
and tried to do [__] full speed just
[__] that I've learned a million times
don't do it don't try to do this and uh
I kind of smartened up in the end I was
like why don't we just slow down here
bill
maybe try to Advance one thing of the 40
things you just tried to learn how to do
in 40 minutes you know
so uh
anyway I guess I'm starting to
understand soccer more and I will always
call it soccer because I know it drives
people [__] nuts
we call it soccer because we already
have football
all right and uh believe it or not the
kicking game is a big part of the game
we actually picked up the ball that's
where it changed
you know as we picked up the ball and
then also if you roll around on the
ground and act like you're in pain
uh you called a woman
or at least she used to be called they
used to be like a [__] insult you
[__] woman
can you imagine saying that now
at least out here what does that mean
they probably have someone acronym for
it wonderful obstinate
mommy oh shut up I get it I get it
you're [__] living your best life
um
could you live it away from me I think
if you wanted to live your best life you
wouldn't be around me because I'm gonna
[__]
probably say more annoying [__] oh
really Bill are you the dangerous guy
hey maybe I am
maybe yeah maybe I'm the guy saying the
things that people whatever the [__]
that expression is
um
anyway so next weekend
the final three
on The Slight Return tour and and for
those of you who don't listen to the
podcast regularly I called it The Slight
Return tour obviously a nod to Jimi
Hendrix but it was also
the amount of times during covid that
they let us out and then told us to go
back inside I wasn't sure if I was going
to be able to do the whole tour and uh
it ended up happening so now I'm kind of
looking back at all these [__]
amazing places they got to play I really
want to thank everybody for showing up
it's been a [__] ridiculous
ridiculous turnout and uh
I enjoyed as much of it as I could as I
was blazing through all of it trying to
make sure uh I got my ACT where it
needed to be and I got three more dates
in three amazingly fun cities
I have New Orleans
everybody knows that place is fun Austin
everybody knows that place is fun it is
a fun [__] place a lot of people
don't know about San Antonio
I always have a good time out there that
place is a good [__] time and it's
got a great airport that is not busy
I love ending like I just ended my tour
in Colorado Springs who the [__] flies
out of Colorado Springs nobody and you
show up and it's wonderful
you walk in there and it's like the
world population is what it should be
you go you go to the big boys
that [__] one up in Denver
that's so [__] big they try to make
it look like the Rocky Mountains with
that goddamn Tent City they put on top
of it I will get uh the Denver
International Airport I will give them
a little tip of the cap I don't know who
[__] complained but finally got it to
stop but they finally stopped that
[__] recording
that I remember you know getting like
two hours sleep back when I used to
drink like a [__] idiot
and and like my move was I'm just going
to stay out and drink and then I'll
sleep on the flight and then I would be
laying there
like literally laying on the airport
carpet waiting for them to call whatever
group I was in
and I always got there super early
because I was always nervous about
missing a [__] plane
I only missed one in my career
um
and I remember just laying there in
every [__] two seconds this recording
would go caution moving sidewalk is
nearing its end please watch your step
thank you caution moving sidewalk is
thank you it was like a sensor
and anytime someone's on the moving
sidewalk to cover themselves I guess
legally they would be uh that [__]
recording
what happened
and
um
I mean it's a [__] airport it's an
International Airport
there was an endless stream of people
with neck pillows pillows I always say
pillows pillows coming down the [__]
thing I thought I shut this goddamn heat
off
um
just an endless [__] see these
goddamn people coming and I would you
just be laying there hungover caution
moving sidewalk as nearing its end
please watch your step thank you
I connected there a few weeks ago they
they got rid of that a long time ago
all right you want to hear some of my
favorite airports
huh
my favorite airports My Favorite Martian
all right
I'll just do I'll just say this
all right when you go to
when you go to Washington DC you fly
into Reagan you don't go to
you go to [__] Dallas you're flying
The Love Field you go into [__]
Chicago
you fly into whatever that [__] other
one is
the hell is it called old lathy what the
[__] is that one
no ORD that's Chicago
Midway
that's the deal
you're flying to La you go to Long Beach
or [__] Ontario
that's what you do you go to the smaller
ones
and yeah you got to drive a little bit
further but it is just such a more
pleasurable [__] experience
than going to the gang bang [__]
airport with every [__]
person that's going to Sea World on
their way to Hawaii
to bet monks [__] coming through
you know they're usually good because
they can just kick their slippers off
um
all right let's do a little read here
on the uh a little wreath you're gonna
do a little read bill you're gonna do a
little cute little [__] read on your
podcast there your big freckled so and
so yes I am
if I can find it oh look at this
this is really interesting all right
fight Camp everybody hey let's be honest
we could all use a little more
motivation when it comes to working out
allow me to introduce to you
uh fight Camp fight Camp is interactive
at home boxing they bring the best
workout in the world into your home and
make it fun explore thousands of
workouts led by expert trainers with
Decades of experience teaching proper
boxing form and technique fight Camp has
live punch counting stats that motivate
you by counting every punch throughout
your workout and pushing you to meet
your goals each round as you progress
you'll unlock achievements and you can
go head to head against other members
whether they're across the country or
across the living room
you're going to fight somebody virtually
uh one of the best things that makes
fight Camp one of the best things about
fight Camp is that it makes boxing
accessible
to everyone
yeah if you got a flat screen TV
uh no matter what Fitness level you're
at this is so funny they're making like
you know like boxing like it's this
[__] Elite Sport it's actually the
sport of [__] the poor
anyway no matter what Fitness level
you're at what your age is
that goddamn box you know what people I
would have boxed I just didn't have the
money
I'm sorry what's your experience with
boxing is you can do it and you're going
to have a great time so join the biggest
boxing community in the world without
leaving your home oh okay yeah I get it
all right this holiday season you'll
also get a heart rate monitor and a
premium Jump Rope for free
so if you got a flat screen TV and you
don't want to go down to a boxing gym
with all those undesirables and you want
to stay in your nice [__] iPad world
this is the [__] for you uh that's an
additional 100 well you know what you
are one less douche on the road there's
an upside uh that's an additional 148
dollar value 148 value for free fight
Camp packages start at just 99 dollars
they also offer some great financing
options so you can get started for as
low as nine dollars a month this is
great you never have to get punched in
the head you can fight somebody
virtually and be the virtual Muhammad
Ali
you can stay in your home gym
this is amazing I had to get started and
to get your free gifts with perch I want
to start like a [__] uh Blood Diamond
[__] workout
you can get the shape of people digging
for blood diamonds without ever leaving
your house we'll give you a virtual
shovel uh to get started and to get your
free gift with the purchase go to
fightcamp.com
that's fightcamp.com
uh every once in a while you gotta you
gotta burn a sponsor of the [__]
joke's there
your class everyone
you know Master Class brings you inside
the minds of the most qualified people
in all areas of life with Master Class
you can learn from the world's best
Minds
can you imagine if this came out in the
1800s this would be a whole different
kind of app anytime anywhere and at your
own pace you can learn French pastry
fundamentals
oh my God I would love to do that
from Dominique and cell that's it I'm
salt
improve your writing skills
from David Mamet or Judy Bloom where the
[__] was this when I was a kid
or learn space exploration from
Astronaut Chris Hadfield that's right
you can actually have an astronaut teach
you how to go to space
I wish this guy did this earlier at
least people with these backyard Rockets
[__] blowing themselves up uh with
over 150 classes from a range of
world-class instructors
uh that thing you've always wanted to do
is closer than you think talk about how
good it feels to feed your curiosity and
learn a new skill I'll tell you this you
know what feels good is that my schedule
is opening up here I don't know if I
mentioned that 5 000 times in this
podcast I think I would absolutely love
to have nothing to do sit there with a
cappuccino you know little [__]
Italian flavor there as I watch
Dominique Ansel teach me how to make
some French pastry the fundamentals
um how was that was that a good was that
how was my rap man I highly recommend
you check it out this holiday give one
annual membership and get one free go to
masterclass.com
today that's masterclass.com
terms apply
all right
can you imagine if Roberto Duran signed
up for that [__]
fight camp
you're fighting him virtually talking
[__] uh Simply Safe you know I believe
home should be where you and your family
feel safest especially over the holidays
this season give yourself and your
family the gift of peace and protection
with the number one rated home security
system Simply Safe and right now Simply
Safe is offering my listeners 40 off a
new security system don't put this off
in an emergency
uh 20 don't put this off sorry
24 7 uh professional monitoring agents
use fast protect TM technology
exclusively from SimpliSafe to capture
critical evidence and verify that the
threat is real so you can get priority
police response Simply Safe as a whole
home security with Advanced sensors for
every room window and door HD security
cameras for inside and out smarter ways
to detect motion that alert you when a
threat is real and even Hazard sensors
that detect fires floods and other
threats to your home 24 7 Professional
monitoring service Services uh usually
caught uh oh sorry professional
monitoring service cost a dollar a day
less than half the price of adt's
traditionally professionally installed
systems uh with top-rated Simply Safe
app stay in complete control of your
system anytime anywhere arm or disarm
unlocked for a guest access to your
camera or adjust system settings don't
miss your chance for massive savings on
my favorite security system get 40 off
any new system at simplysafe.com today
that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe like SimpliSafe
all right
this says Bill great emails you guys are
always sending great emails uh all right
we're going to start off with with a sad
one but also uh respectful nod to a
legend Christy alley uh rest in peace
Christy alley hey Bill I know celebrity
deaths hit the public differently but
I'd like to say Christy alley didn't get
enough love after her passing yeah I was
surprised that wasn't
trending on Twitter
my wife said she got a little sideways
with her politics which I would say that
that meant she wasn't a bleeding heart
liberal
so then all these open-minded liberals
chose to [__] ignore her
um
which is ridiculous after all the great
work that she did amazing amazing
actress stunning absolutely stunning uh
she was a badass on chairs this person
says and always a Class Act she turned
down roles she would have been
drastically underpaid for
uh um
wait she turned down roles she would
have been drastically underpaid for oh
she didn't take [__] good for her and
didn't ask for a medal in return
uh
uh I don't care about her politics
either neither do I
I don't care about anybody's politics I
I really don't I don't give a [__] you
know what I mean I might not like
somebody who's a potential leader I'll
do that but I'm not gonna [__] waste
my time
you know you're into politics great you
care you care about the country that's
fantastic
I don't have to agree with what you you
you're thinking and and Christianity was
not her politics she was a [__]
amazing amazing
I mean
she stepped in on Cheers
like do you know something the casting
on that show was unbelievable because it
was such a huge hit
coach died and then Woody Harrelson had
to step in
and they picked the guy
who absolutely crushed it continued to
crush it Kelsey Grammer stepped in he
crushed it and Kirsty alley
all right
that's the level
she was at
um
I always loved her had a huge crush on
her when she was in when she was on um
when she was on Cheers when I first saw
you know that [__] amazing voice
whatever happened you know all those
women back then there's so many of them
had Demi Moore had that voice Kirstie
Alley had that voice that chick from
Romancing the Stone
the hell was her name I don't know Kelly
McGillis Ike Turner
um anyway yeah rest in peace uh Christie
alley and it'd be nice if liberals would
[__] lay off people just because
they're [__] conservatives you know
[__] relax
[__] [__]
um all right
and I'm a liberal I love when people do
that
I you know even people like they they
act like they're the other parties so
they can leave a comment on YouTube
I think Donald Trump is the worst
president ever
and I'm a conservative are you
all right Bill Maher and sheep brains
all right well that's this is this
casting a wide net here
hey Bill Burr I've been a casual fan of
Bill Maher for a while
I love casual fan you check in every
once in a while
dressed in a Hawaiian shirt uh I really
enjoyed your interview with him that's
one of the most fun interviews
I ever had man I I had no idea what what
to expect
when he sat down and uh I was like oh my
God I don't know [__] about what the
[__] going on in the world what are we
going to talk about and I had an
absolute [__] blast with that guy so
I'm glad you enjoyed it
um and it prompted me to subscribe to
his podcast as well look at that look at
me
driving subscriptions
see I made that about myself uh I've
been seeing a lot of people trashing him
for commenting on insane things that are
occurring on what's normally considered
his side
yeah it's called being a [__] adult
that's why I love that guy because if
Liberals are doing something stupid even
if he's he is a liberal right as far as
I know he'll give him [__] for it
um that [__] whole ideology that that
you're a conservative so you can't trash
anything that conservatives are doing
um that's like you know
I don't know that'd be like I always
said like if I start trashing
my home sports team that doesn't mean I
hate the team it means I don't like the
direction the coach is taking it in
oh Jesus
anyway this person said I'd like to say
[__] off to all the one-sided [__]
who have
Drawn Lines in the sand with people
uh who are meant to entertain or happen
to give an alternate opinion
these people are exhausting you know why
they're exhausting because there's so
many of them
they just keep coming like those people
back in the day on that moving sidewalk
that's nearing its end please watch your
step thank you that will never leave my
brain
um
that's right up there with that Connect
Four
the new something something came from
something something but watch out your
opponent can sneak up on you and win the
game I won where I can't see here
diagonally pretty sneaky sis
that anybody over 40 knows what the [__]
I'm talking about everybody else think I
just had a stroke that was The Connect
Four commercial from like [__] 1980.
um
I don't know why I never forgot that
anyway they are constantly evaluating
who's on their stupid team in life and
get this when I don't acclimate
according like they do
I'm told I'm the sucker
yeah
um well I mean a lot of that has to do
with the fact that we can all talk to
each other now
and we're on the internet and then all
rules of like decency
you know went away
and uh what's awful is I feel like
the internet actually influences
real human interaction as opposed to
cyber interaction like it's it's winning
bad that reminds me back in the day when
VHS won over beta and evidently beta was
the better system
or the gas combustion engine one over
the electric
engine people still laugh at electric
cars like they're weak and they're for
like [__] and meanwhile you can be in
a [__] Tesla
filled with kids and groceries in an SUV
style and you can beat a Corvette off
the line like
it's just far superior if you're into
speed
I mean I know they don't sound as cool I
mean I I kind of I love them both
you know what I mean although I don't
I'm not liking the new exhaust systems
on the [__] Mustangs the Corvettes I
saw a charger today
I don't know what that sound is supposed
to be
but it's like why don't you give these
people the engine they deserve in that
[__] car but you like those people
who put like the high performance
I've talked about this before that you
know
loud you know slow car loud exhaust
phenomenon
yeah that's like the [__] boob job
for a goddamn car
uh Botox or some [__] it's like
everybody knows your car's safe we've
heard it for the last 10 miles and we're
keeping up with you
um all right Operation Condor
all right
hey Billy Cheese tricks
Billy Cheese tricks what the [__] does
that mean
oh you know that reminds me of I
actually after the show last night
we ordered from this authentic German
restaurant out in Colorado Springs
and I hadn't been eating like an [__]
so I just ordered a pretzel
and uh the the dipping sauces were this
was this spicy mustard that that was
sweet and then it was just cheese
all right
it's nice to get in touch with my roots
every once in a while you know it's I
think there's a lot of Germans out there
because a long time ago
I think I was in Colorado and I stayed
at like a bed and breakfast I was so I
was thinking that you know I have done
out of all the states
that I did College gigs in I would say
Wisconsin Illinois and Colorado
were the ones that I went to the most
and I remember Colorado
for some reason because I always had
these crazy experiences
that's why I remember the caution moving
sidewalk thing in my head
because I was always going there
like I went there I went to a game at
Mile High Stadium like the last year
before they got rid of that and I want
to say I went
the airport we either had just opened
I went to a [__] Nuggets game at
McNichols Arena
like uh Colorado like Denver was so
[__] different
like Denver was Denver was like I know
they'd already dealt with people in the
80s starting to move out there but like
it was a lot [__] smaller
uh I remember like sneaking into the
Comedy Works
being like hey I'm a comedian they're
like all right we usually you don't do
this and Adam Ferrara was headlining I
remember sitting there going oh my God
someday
can you imagine you know working at this
club it was like that period in my
my career oh [__] Billy Dreamboat you
know and um
I remember driving all the way out to
Grand Junction in a [__] snowstorm
going through the Rocky Mountains on the
70.
through that [__] tunnel I remember
getting off I remember going up to
Greeley
a whole bunch of times when they had a
slaughterhouse and they had like bad
smell days and they you'd call them up
being like listen it smells too much
like death and they'd have to [__]
lay off killing the cows and [__]
and uh of the steers
um so anyway one time um well I remember
another time I [__]
got in my car and I was late and I was
driving like a you know no I wasn't late
I was just tired I got in the car and I
drove an hour and a half in the wrong
direction so it's going to take me three
hours run round trip to get back where I
[__] started
uh I did that twice in my career once by
myself in in Colorado and once with Joe
to Rosa when I first met him
in [__] New York we drove an hour and
a half in the wrong direction
away from New York City
we turned a two-hour drive into a five
and a half hour drive
so anyway
I remember driving back when I realized
I went the wrong direction racing back
and I was in the middle of [__]
nowhere
and I came up over this hill and this
guy was like in a Bronco that had a blue
light on the [__] dashboard or
something
and he almost drove me off the road
going the other way and he did like a
fishtail turn around pulled me over
and he walked up to my car and he was
[__] young and
livid and I remember I was so in the
sticks all he had was the cop shirt
it was tucked into like Wrangler jeans
and he had like boots on I was like
Jesus Christ This Guy's gonna [__]
this is I'm gonna get this is gonna be
like uh
Fargo
gonna get [__] whacked right here
um
still made the gig though but anyway
getting back to the German restaurant I
stayed at a [__] Airbnb
with this guy first generation
from Germany I swear to God he looked
like the tank driver in Kelly's Heroes
the German guy in the end
um
I remember it was [__] creepy
because there wasn't a lock on the
bedroom door I was just basically
staying in his house and at night I was
laying in bed and he was walking up and
down the hallway a couple of times
how old people do that [__] they're
always [__] up at night you know
just watching a shadow going underneath
the [__] doors like Jesus Christ and
then of course I was in like this
[__] really high bed with like the
canopy over the top of it
they look like [__] you know Martha
Washington got banged in it
and uh
the next morning you know he was like
well it's your breakfast is ready yeah
right
he didn't talk like that I can't do the
German accent and I came downstairs
and it was like this authentic German
breakfast and all all I remember was
everything was like
these weird sides but it was delicious
but the egg he had a hard-boiled egg and
it was like almost you know it sits on
top of that little trophy
you know and then you're supposed to
take the spoon and just sort of whack it
and then start
peeling it
I just I felt like I was in that scene
in the end of this the second Hannibal
Lecter you know when he starts stir
frying Ray Liotta's [__] brains
um I don't know why I just thought of
that oh yeah no we went to the [__]
German restaurant so I ordered this that
pretzel that's right that's right anyway
let's get uh let's
do some more uh reads here all right
Operation Condor
hey Billy Cheese tricks
um in some of your podcasts you've
voiced some concerns in traveling to a
Latin American country because of the
fear of knowing that American
governments have done some [__] up
[__] here
uh parentheses not like the same
countries
have done some [__] up [__] to
themselves
uh
you know but it creates like a [__]
desperate situation and then I show up
all Pasty
uh that happened to me when I was in
[__] uh Costa Rica I went down there
a long time ago I was getting all these
and I was thinking like all right we
haven't done anything down here right I
was getting all these dirty looks and
then I realized I ended up looking up
going what the [__] did we do down here
and like Dole and Chiquita banana
somehow cut a deal with their government
they took over all of these Farmers
lands made the farmers stay there and
[__] Farm the bananas for these big
corporations and they didn't pay them
[__] and then I [__] show up like hey
how's it going with my dumb brochure my
hipster hat on yeah you're gonna get
some looks
um anyway
this person says I just wanted to give
some history pointers
for your benefit uh without the
anti-American tone that some of my Latin
American people have
uh rather than educate normal citizens
from the U.S of what happened all right
let's hear it let's hear this guy's
version
all right the main reason why Latin
American countries have some resentment
over folks from the United States is
because of Operation Condor
and he has a link here it's basically
was the plan
and involvement of past American
governments in taking down
democratically elected officials and
installing dictatorships between the 70s
and 90s for economic military and
political interests oh if you want to oh
if you want a great book confessions of
an economic Hitman read that
and that was that thing you know okay to
let you know our side of it
because they didn't let us know what we
what they were doing down there when we
were growing up we were like why does
this country hate us we gave them
billions of dollars in Aid
and what our government didn't tell us
was that you guys had to pay it back
like they would be like hey we're going
to build you a dam
and then you can have electricity and oh
boy you're going to be and you're going
to make all this [__] money and we
knew that you wouldn't because you
didn't have the infrastructure yet
and then what happened was you owed
money on the dam and you couldn't take
you couldn't pay it and then we came in
and said all right you either got to
give us the damn
uh or you got to let us put uh put a
base down here so we can protect you and
blah blah something like that it was a
real [__] Boss Hog [__] deal
um anyway many innocent people died and
the wounds have never been really dealt
with or publicly recognized by the U.S
yeah and the CIA and shit's [__]
horrible
it's [__] horrible here in Puerto
Rico we have many polarized polarized
views over the actual Colonial status
with the U.S maybe you you would like to
check on that too at some point but our
story is different from South America
all right
well I would love to go down there I
just don't want to [__] pay the price
for the [__] bankers and whatever
they did to you guys uh but many of us
many of us recognize that citizens of
the US are not really to blame for these
actions and I've met many American
tourists here that have no problem
whatsoever in their time spent so don't
fear my dear Billy bats on Philly Vance
oh boy on coming to the tropics or some
other Latin American spot with your
lovely family enjoy our great cultures
food and weather just bring sunblack
some Block it's not black was that a
[__] Freudian slip just bring
sunblock my freckled friend uh make
Puerto Rico a first stop I'd [__] go
to Puerto Rico in a second
I would do that in a second if I could
sell some tickets uh last thing I enjoy
the movie uh The Departed a lot I know
you're a good fellow fan too as a dude
from Massachusetts slash Boston does it
portray an attitude of the folks up
there or is it overly acted
and this says I guess this is thank you
and go [__] yourself gracias Yvette uh
Al carajo
um
as a dude from Massachusetts does it
portray the attitude of the folks uh I
would Mark Wahlberg
and uh Alec Baldwin
definitely had that wound up obviously
Matt Damon he was like from there and
everything
uh and I thought Leonardo did a great
job too I mean that was a really [__]
you know Martin Sheen that's got some of
my favorite actors of all time in it
um but I would say as far as like wound
up [__] lunatics
uh I would say the way Wahlberg did his
character and the way Alec Baldwin did
his
um
as far as guys that I ran into so what
you have to understand me is I'm
Suburban bill I didn't [__] grow up
in that Goodwill Hunting [__] the
Dorchester [__] all of that stuff the
fighter all of those movies that was all
[__] those are all [__] lunatics
I was out in the safe suburbs playing
street hockey in a [__] cul-de-sac
there was enough lunatics
in my town
all right it was just yeah it was
definitely uh
yeah but I mean I don't know that you
know
I'll be honest with you that I mean that
was basically talking about you know
Whitey bulger's alleged
uh relationship with the FBI I believe
so I wasn't in that [__] world
and uh
I'm gonna follow the rules
I don't know if they still exist but
like I'm not going to comment on them
I mean you know when they when they used
to do movies about that [__] like uh
you know when they were actually doing
the thing about Whitey Bulger and Billy
Bulger
the Brotherhood they set it down in
[__] uh
Providence Rhode Island so they wouldn't
have a [__] problem
and I know that uh there's a Scorsese
movie where he goes our friends in
Kansas City he was actually talking
about the Chicago mob from what I heard
he didn't want a problem with them and
that [__] narcos show they were down
in Mexico
scouting locations
and the guy scouting location got
[__] whacked I mean that's like I
don't know
yeah that's all you know like I said I
was old Billy street hockey you know I
had a [__] paper route
you know
you know I'm not in that world don't
pretend to be either all right
cold-blooded snake oh [__]
he's a cold-blooded snake looking to his
eye
he's got something something um all
right cold-blooded snake dude
um I don't know if you've seen this
story or not but here it goes this woman
owns a python oh Jesus what could go
wrong
she just lets it roam around her house
like it pays rent or something
well I hope she kept it well fed not
only that she sleeps with the thing
She lays in the fetal position and it
circles her
like cradles her while they sleep
no reptiles do not spoon that thing is
like keeping itself warm until it's
hungry
one night she wakes up in the middle of
the night and notices the snake is gone
being so tired she strips she drifts
back and I said strips what's going on
with me she drifts back to off to sleep
uh the next couple of days
she notices that the snake is not eating
and that's because it's full
being a concerned pet owner she takes it
to the vet the vet x-rays it and is
stunned that there's nothing in its
stomach oh
okay look at me trying to be the
crocodile hunter there I thought I knew
what I was doing he sits down with the
owner and tries to
gauge their home life she lets the vet
know that he just slithers around like
it's normal he asks how it sleeps she
says they sleep together and describes
their sleeping habits
she calls it her guardian because she
feels safe
so safe when it cradles her is this
going to go in a sexual Direction I
don't want to read this
the vet is horrified and realizes what's
happening
he then proceeds to tell her
that the snake
the snake's stomach is completely empty
because it's making room for a big meal
I.E the owner holy [__]
yeah that's a [__] reptile
dude
she's alarmed at this point rightfully
so if she had gone one more night
without going to the vet she'd probably
be eaten
laughing my ass off it's not funny but
it's just like damn bro yeah
wow
well I mean she was acting like a
sacrificial lamb dude people are [__]
I'm telling you human beings dude
they're [__] egos they're [__]
Egos and you know and I read this
[__] article
was talking about why dumb people think
they're smart and smart people think
they're dumb
it was really fascinating and then it
got boring
um
like
this is a guy like
she doesn't know [__] about snakes
so she thinks she knows everything about
snakes
right she thinks she knows all there is
to [__] know so she lets this thing
[__] sleep with her the veterinarian
knows way more about snakes but I bet if
you asked him what do you think dude I
don't know what the [__] that thing's
gonna do it's a wild animal
what I have learned through all my years
of learning [__] about animals is you
don't know what the [__] a wild animal
is gonna do
so he wouldn't you know this if a
veterinarian would let the thing wander
around the [__] house
anyway
then you know what happens she keeps it
oh my God
and just make sure she keeps it in in
its tank at night from now on
guess what a race is Billy I was gonna
say this earlier
a goddamn animal cracker
uh
oh my God that's such a great joke that
works on two levels
animal cracker animal crack all right
he's in the animals all right you guys
are nuts uh anyways I'm glad you started
feeling better cannot wait for old dads
to come out great don't get a reptile as
a pet go Love Yourself YouTube video
below if you want to know the details of
this situation what the
[__] I would send this to Joe Rogan this
no but there's no way he doesn't know
about this he always knows all the
[__] crazy animal [__]
um
dude what the f oh my God
that thing was basically like all right
if you're gonna make it this easy
that thing stopped [__] eating
because it was gonna [__] eat her
uh
as horrific as that is the fact that she
lets it
can you imagine what I was thinking the
first night
going like oh my God
this is the [__] easiest meal ever
[__]
why did I eat that goat God damn it
oh well
what are you gonna do it happens
you know
and then she does it again the next
night
and then the thing was like
oh [__]
this is going to be an every night
[__] thing I'm just gonna stop eating
I'll eat this oh my God it would [__]
it would eat her and then puke up her
clothes
can you [__] imagine how [__]
stupid are people I don't know
oh it's someone who can't stand snakes I
respect them I stay away from them I'm
not into [__] reptiles
from snakes all the way up to the Komodo
dragon
you know back to the Gila monster and
and over to uh the salamanders whatever
the [__] they I don't [__] with reptiles
they're fascinating you know I like
looking at them on TV or at the zoo or
some [__]
does PETA get mad about reptiles
or is it just mammals
we'll discuss that on another podcast
all right that's the podcast everybody
uh Thursday
um
this week I have a [__] amazing guest
one of my favorite comedians and people
in this business
uh on Thursday and uh that's it go [__]
yourselves and I will check in on you
with that person
uh on Thursday I'll see you